shall we get started good evening
everyone this is the second of this
year's to pre-election panels on the
state of the American economy the
purpose and objective of these
discussions is not to persuade any of
you how you should vote or for whom you
should vote but rather to illuminate the
major economic issues that confront the
nation at this time and to try to look
at them from various angles and
encourage you to think more deeply for
yourselves about the right what what
correct policy prescriptions might flow
from the analysis you'll hear so we're
very fortunate to have a really
sensational panel for you tonight all of
whom will have a role we're going to
have three initials sets of remarks and
then some opportunity for the other
panelists to comment on the
presentations that preceded them then
we'll have a little bit of panel
discussion amongst ourselves that I will
moderate and then open up to questions
and I hope that you know it each phase
of this discussion will prove
illuminating and invaluable to all of
you very delighted to welcome back as
the person who will be our lead speaker
this evening michael woodford who's a
professor of economics at columbia
university but michael is an alumnus of
the very school were sitting in the Yale
Law School where he took his first
economics course in 1977 I think or 60
from none other than me um and and and
went on to shift gears after graduated
the Yale Law School get a PhD in
economics and become one of the leading
macroeconomists of his generation and
then we'll have four members of the of
the faculty of the Department of
Economics who will speak he'll be
Michael be followed immediately by john
zakappa lyst who's who's
your second from the right as you face
the front and then bill Nordhaus will
speak about the about macroeconomic
issues and then we'll have some
discussion remarks from Bob Shiller and
Alice sowinski I think it'll be very
lively and interesting for everyone I
think that will hope to engage you all
in in discussion when the question
period does arise there are two
microphones located it one in each aisle
and if you have a question when we get
to that point the best solution is not
to raise your hand but they simply rise
and go to the microphone and I'll call
on people in sequence from 11 microphone
and the other so with no further ado I'm
delighted to ask michael woodford to you
have an opening talk about the but
macroeconomic conditions since the the
onset of the Great Recession I could
have said the focus of this panel will
be the macroeconomy what's happened to
it over the last few years and what
kinds of what kinds of potential policy
options there are in the years ahead the
last panel as you know focused on
taxation and health care to central
issues in the in the current
presidential debates but the overall
question of how to get the macro economy
moving again how to raise aggregate
aggregate output in the economy and
reduce unemployment will be the major
focus of today's discussion Michael
thank you it's a it's a great pleasure
to be to be back at Yale in addition to
having had President Levin as an
undergraduate instructor before he was
president level he was just professor 11
Professor Shiller was also one of my
teachers in graduate school and so this
feels a little bit like an oral exam he
has to talk to you but I'm very happy to
be to be able to be back at Yale so I
wanted to start my talk and and to
something that set the stage for what
we're going to be talking about in all
the presentations by first reminding you
something about what the US economy has
has just been through and the extent to
which there are still concerns about the
health of the economy first of all the
most obvious measure of the extent to
which the recession that we went through
was a serious one is to look at the path
of real GDP a measure of overall
activity in the economy and that's shown
by this blue line and the two shaded
blue regions are the two most recent
recessions both periods of slowdowns in
economic growth and you can see that
that most recent one the recession that
started in late two thousand seven and
officially ended in the middle of 2009
involved a very substantial decline in
in real production in the economy a much
bigger decline than for example the
previous recession back in two thousand
one another thing I wanted to point out
the slow is getting back to a normal
level of activity and you can see that
it took until road in 2011
or GED to be back with head and at the
beginning of the recession but the
dashed red line is showing the cbo's
estimate of potential output which
should have continued growing as the
labor force grows and productive
capacity presumably is growing for other
reasons and giving that estimate the
continents capacity we're still way
below it as a second quarter of this
year around six percent still below the
economy's level of capacity and that gap
is in fact not being closed very quickly
so that's a reason for continuous
concerns another way of asking whether
predict production in general has gotten
back to where it ought to be is just to
divide it by the population and look at
real GDP per capita here you see even on
this measure it hasn't gotten back at
all to where it was at at the beginning
of the recession and of course just
getting back to where it was with itself
not be that much of a victory since
ordinarily real GDP per capita it has a
steady upper trend looking at employment
is a particular concern even more
worrying and just thinking about GP as a
measure of what's going on is the number
of people able to have jobs here what
I'm plotting is employment in the
non-farm business sector you see it fell
very sharply during the recession it has
been coming steadily back since late in
2009 there's been a lot of discussion in
the electoral campaign of the millions
of new jobs created since then but if
you look at a comparison of that to the
number that we're lost you can see we're
still not close to being back to even
the level of employment that there
existed at the beginning of the
recession and again the labor force has
been growing so even that would not be
that much of a victory another way to
think about employment relative to the
size of the labor force is to look at
the unemployment rate and that's a
statistic that a lot of attention has
been paid to the last few years one sees
that it went up very sharply from below
five percent unemployment up to a little
above ten percent unemployment
as a result of the recession that's a
much bigger increase than say in that
last recession about three times as
large in terms of the number of
percentage points increase again we've
been making progress since late in 2009
unemployment has been slowly coming down
but it's a bit of very slow agonizing
process you know not anywhere close to
halfway back to undoing the increase
that it occurred this is another way of
looking at just how big that increase in
unemployment is compared to a longer
series of past recessions you see that
the increase to a little above ten
percent is a bigger higher level of
unemployment than even in the worst
point in previous recessions in the
period since world war two except for
one of them the 1982 recession even when
you compare it to the 1982 recession I
think that the baseline that
unemployment was increasing above was
substantially higher at that point in
time and a lot of economists estimate of
what they think the sustainable level of
unemployment in the US economy at that
time would have estimated that it was
significantly higher maybe as much as
two percentage points higher than what
it was before the most recent recession
and so the fact that it didn't get quite
as high as it did in nineteen eighty-two
doesn't mean that in some obvious ways
this isn't even more dramatic increase
in unemployment you also see that where
we've gotten back to now is of course
still a very high level of unemployment
compared to even the worst points in
most of the previous recessions another
way of seeing what's disturbing about
the recent behavior of unemployment is
not to just look at the overall
statistic but particularly at the number
of longer term unemployed hear what's
being plaut is is the share of the
unemployed who have been unemployed for
27 weeks or more and you see if you look
at that number it went up a lot during
the recession and went up a lot more
than in any of those previous recessions
since World War two so particularly this
problem of longer term unemployment has
been particularly severe and is coming
back
only very slowly that's a big concern
both because of the degree of distress
it involves for the people in that
situation but also because of worries
about the continuing consequences for
the economy of long-term unemployment as
people's skills are degraded in their
attachment to the workforce weakens and
so there's serious concern that they'll
be lasting negative consequences of this
kind of prolonged period of high
long-term unemployment you've seen that
the progress back from the recovery has
been only partial so far there's been a
certain amount of commentary recently
about how slow it is and some suggestion
that maybe it means the policy measures
that have been enacted have in fact been
ineffective because we haven't bounced
back faster from the recovery one thing
a lot of people have pointed out is that
compared to these previous us recessions
since World War two this is a relatively
slow recovery and that's true this is
looking at the decline in employment
relative to where it was at the
beginning of the recession in percentage
points for each of those us recessions
since World War two and you see that in
the early ones employment would fall and
then it would bounce back pretty quickly
as a pretty sharp v-shaped recession say
in 1948 or 1953 many of those early
recessions you fell sharply and then
came back very quickly the red line here
which is the most recent recession it
fell further but it's also been coming
back to normal much more slowly than in
those previous cases on the other hand
it's worth pointing out and many people
have that this is not so unusual if you
compare the current recession to
previous examples of recessions that
resulted from systemic banking crises as
our most recent recession has Carmen
Reinhart and Ken Rogoff in particular of
stressed this difference between the
recession's associated with banking
crises in their recent book this time is
is different and if one makes a
comparison of that kind one finds that
it's common for unempl
to return to normal only very slowly and
one could argue that this time the
response has perhaps even been faster
than some of the others perhaps because
of the very prompt policy response this
time so for example the response of
employment in the case of the Great
Depression is now plotted on this that's
the dotted black line there and you see
that employment was falling for the
first year and a half in this recession
at the same rate essentially as it did
in the beginning of the Great Depression
but it turns up then much sooner and in
the case of the depression even 10 years
after it was only basically back at the
level of employment that there had been
at the beginning so it's not obviously
compared to that things are going badly
this time the chart is also showing you
several other systemic banking crisis
episodes in other countries from the 70s
80s and 90s and you see that in all of
them employment remains low for a very
long period of time here similarly the
unemployment rates for those different
systemic banking crises and you see that
it both increased more in many of them
than it has in the u.s. this time but
also that unemployment would say easily
take a decade or longer to get back to
its its previous level and so from that
point of view perhaps there is evidence
at least consistent with the view that
the fairly aggressive measures on some
dimensions that have been taken to
combat the recession may have in fact
had some important effect I want to
focus in my remarks on one particular
aspect of the policy response to the
recession and that's the response of the
Federal Reserve that there has been a
certain amount of controversy about I
think the Fed has become much more
controversial in the last couple of
years than it had been before the recent
reset a recession and one of the reasons
for this is that the Fed policy has been
very unusual on a whole set of
dimensions in the last few years the
federal funds rate which previously had
been the main tool of policy of the Fed
has been taken to historically low
levels and kept at this extremely low
level
for a surprisingly long time the Fed has
also made a lot of announcements about
its intention to maintain accommodative
policies for a long time into the future
it's very unusual for it to be talking
that way about future policy and in
particular to be talking about future
policies so far in the future there's
been a very large increase in its
balance sheet and in particular
remarkable increase in the supply of
bank reserves the kind of assets on the
balance sheet of the Fed have changed it
used to be mainly Treasury securities
mainly short-term Treasury securities
instead it's been holding a lot of other
types of assets for a while in 2008 and
2009 there was a whole series of special
liquidity and credit facilities that the
Fed set up there were an unusual
dimension of policy and finally one of
the most controversial things that the
Fed got involved in was some
interventions to try to avoid more
disorderly liquidations of particular
financial firms in particular its
involvement in the liquidations of bear
stearns and AIG back in 2008 so this is
showing you the feds target for the
federal funds rate how it plunged during
the recession eventually going down to a
target band between zero and only a
quarter of a percent which is where it's
been since December of 2008 and that's
very unusual for it to go that low
particularly striking that then it
stayed at that level and not moved since
then I mentioned the feds I'm making
statements about future policy when it
introduced this unusually low interest
rate targeted announced it would be
expected to maintain it for some time by
the following March they began saying
they expected to maintain it for an
extended period in August of 2011 they
adopted a more aggressive kind of
guidance about future policy saying they
expected to maintain it at least through
mid-2013 it was unusual they were
announcing a date but it was also
unusual that the date was about two
years in the future at the time that
they announced it much further in the
future than people had fought the
extended period would have referred to
last January they increase that to
saying they expect to maintain the
accommodative policy at least through
late 2004
and in September they went further and
said they expect to maintain it at least
through mid-2015 and also added a
statement that they expect to maintain
the low interest rates for a
considerable time after the economic
recovery strengthens I talked about the
changes in the balance sheet here you
see how dramatically it's just grown in
size since late 2008 but another
striking thing that purple region is the
supply of bank reserves you can see a
little bit of purple over at the left if
you look really close but many of you
probably aren't close enough to tell
that there were bank reserves at all
before late 2008 it's grown gigantically
relative to the previous supply bank
reserves you now around it a trillion
and a half of them that's a massive
change in the policy with regard to the
supply of bank reserves looking at the
asset side of the balance sheet it had
mostly been Treasury securities the blue
region up until two thousand eight a
variety of other unusual types of assets
start getting added to the balance sheet
after that the big one now is that light
blue region the mortgage-backed
securities that have become a very big
part of the fed's balance sheet that it
was previously not really holding any of
so some questions that this has raised
there are many questions I think that
it's raised one point of controversy is
whether the Fed simply has too much
discretion and too much power that it
can exercise without having to be
accountable to anyone else given that
it's doing lots of things that people
had not maybe realized it could do
before and not expect it may be that it
ever would do now we see them doing
these things there are questions about
whether it's been intervening in markets
too much their questions about whether
some of its current actions might be
dangerously inflationary and particular
that massive increase in the supply of
bank reserves has been argued by some
people to be something that's building
up a potential for massive future
inflation and finally these statements
talking about future policy years in
advance some think that's really
reckless because if you're making
promises about policy that far in the
future you're tying your hands or the
hands of your successors in a
that can't make sense if you have no
idea what economic conditions are really
going to be like in 2014 or 2015 in
trying to address these things I think
it's important to at least separate two
different parts of what the Fed is been
doing it's obviously been doing many
things I think it's important to at
least distinguish though between what
I'll call phase 1 and phase 2 of these
unconventional policies phase one which
i would call basically the things it was
doing through 2009 were essentially
unusual actions that were motivated as
emergency measures to counteract a
perceived breakdown or threat of
complete breakdown of financial
intermediation in the US economy John
Gina couplers I think we'll talk more
about what was going on in the financial
sector and what the problem was the Fed
was essentially trying to respond to
this in two ways one a providing credit
through special means to fan the
financial sector to avoid further
failures of financial institutions that
it was feared could lead to a complete
collapse of the financial system
secondly the Fed stepped in itself as a
lender in some cases because it
perceived the financial sector is not
providing credit where it was needed and
temporarily the Fed was was stepping in
itself phase two is instead about
something else since 2010 the financial
sector has been in a more healthy and
more normally functioning situation the
unconventional policy measures haven't
all ended why well it's because of this
slow return of the real economy to
normal that I was showing you the
previous slides about in this second
phase the Fed has not had different
goals that it's normal goals basically
it's been thinking about it the usual
goals of monetary stabilization policy
which is keeping the economy operating
it close to its potential while keeping
the lid on inflation and that's
basically what it's been having to think
about since 2010 but it's been pursuing
these standard goals through
non-standard means why because it's
normal means which would be cutting
nominal interest rates wasn't possible
because this is zero lower bound on the
federal funds rate had already been
reached evaluating some of the specific
things I think
that probably the most controversial
thing the Fed had done was getting
involved in the rescues of particular
institutions and I think there's good
arguments for saying it's not obviously
ideal for the central bank to be making
decisions of that kind about who to bail
out on its own because it's not a
political institution and doesn't have
political accountability in their
defense I think one would have to say
that the things the Fed was doing in
2008 it did only in coordination with
the Treasury I think one could view it
as acting as the agent of the Treasury
if you say why was it involved as an
agent it was because no one else was
able to mobilize the funds quickly to do
the things were being done the Treasury
itself couldn't have access to funds
without Congress appropriating them that
would be a slow process the Fed could
take action quickly over a weekend if
the emergency suddenly appeared over a
weekend as as was happening and done so
it's not so much that the Fed wanted to
seize this kind of power but felt that
under those circumstances no one else
could act and that they needed to to the
extent that this is considered
problematic I think it's worth pointing
out that the dodd-frank act has already
taken away the feds authority to do this
so if it was a problem it's not supposed
to occur again I think a question about
that is whether we do have an
alternative mechanism for the next time
this happens the next time the Fed will
not be able to step in presumably
dodd-frank will also set up some other
resolution mechanism for the big banks
to solve this let's hope that that side
of things also does get taken care of
with regard to the special credit
facilities that were set up essentially
the Fed viewed itself as having to be a
financial intermediary substituting for
the things that would normally being
done by the private financial sector
because some parts of the financial
sector were basically not functioning
here's an example of the kind of thing
that motivated the feds stepping in and
some evidence that it had an effect
what's being plotted here are spreads
between yields on certain categories of
commercial paper and the level of the
interest rate that banks expected to be
bought able to borrow in the federal
funds market over
the next month and what you see is these
spreads shoot up substantially in
September of 2008 and that's after
Lehman Brothers has failed and various
other dramatic things are happening in
the financial markets the spreads shoot
up and this is evidence certainly the
Fed took it as I think reasonably took
it as evidence that financial markets
were no longer functioning efficiently
to ensure that people in different parts
of the financial sector were able to
borrow on similar terms what actually
happened here in particular was that the
money market mutual funds that had
normally been buying the commercial
paper were suddenly unable to obtain
funding there was a scare that money
market mutual funds could fail people
were pulling their money out of them
they were no longer able to finance the
commercial paper market so these
commercial paper spreads are shooting up
what the Fed did was set up a facility
the commercial paper funding facility
that's what the CP FF up there stands
for and the amount of commercial paper
the Fed bought under this new facility
is shown by the solid blue line so it
comes in a few weeks after these spreads
are shooting up it's directly in
response to that the spreads on the
lower three lines on the chart come down
immediately once the Fed sets up this
facility and starts buying those are the
three types of commercial paper in the
chart that the Fed was buying those were
eligible to be purchased under the
facility those spreads immediately come
down so it does seem that there's an
effect of the kind that was desired
which is to restore financing on more
normal terms as seen by bringing these
spreads back to a more normal level you
can also see from the figure that the
feds involvement in the market didn't
last very long the solid blue line is
the feds holding of commercial paper by
a year later it's basically being
completely phased out it was a very
temporary program in response to a very
temporary emergency and I think in
general all of the special credit and
liquidity facilities are like this this
shows you the amount of lending by the
Fed under those different special
programs they were essentially all wound
down like
early in 2010 what about the more recent
phase continuing unconventional policies
well the justification for that is that
as I showed you before output has
remained still far below potential for
several years at the same time inflation
has remained subdued even below the
fed's normal target rate of inflation
and under those circumstances they
thought further monetary stimulus is
justified but further cuts in the
federal fund rate weren't possible hence
they've tried to use a variety of
unconventional policies to provide
further stimulus what about the worry
that this big increase in the supply of
bank reserves is something that should
soon or later cause massive inflation I
think that's a misunderstanding it's
based on the view that in the past big
increases in bank reserves much smaller
increases than that one would in fact
stimulate spending and eventually the
level of prices in the economy but that
occurred because in the past the
interest being paid on reserves was well
below other money market interest rates
so there was a very substantial
opportunity cost to banks to holding
reserves so increasing the amount they
had to hold by even a modest amount
would require important changes in
financial conditions to get banks to be
willing to hold the additional reserves
that has not been true in this more
recent period because other money market
interest rates are very low right now
they're as low as the level of interest
being paid on the reserves what if that
changes what if the level of interest
rates elsewhere in financial markets
that are necessary to contain inflation
Rises substantially and so it wouldn't
be possible for people to still be
willing to hold these large reserves
without paying a lot more interest on
them it's still going to be possible for
the Fed to adjust policy to head off the
inflationary pressure in one of two ways
it could either remove the reserves and
if you say well it's not plausible they
could remove them quickly Japan in fact
did something similar with its
quantitative easing experiment in the
early 2000s when they ended that
experiment in 2006 the newly created
reserves were largely taken out in the
space of a few months on the other hand
I think maybe even more plausibly the
Fed could start paying a higher interest
rate on reserves so they would continue
not to be an opportunity cost of holding
them in that way would be possible for
interest rates in general and the
economy come higher if that became
necessary to contain inflation so I
don't think it's inevitable for some
mechanical reason that the current level
of bank reserves should be causing
inflation there could be a question a
potential risk here about whether the
Fed would take prompt action if it was
necessary to do one of the two things I
just mentioned when conditions change
but I don't think that's a question of
economic feasibility that you know is
conceivably a question of political will
and that's something we might want to
worry about in an environment when the
Fed is under many more political
constraints at present then used to be
true a few years ago there haven't been
signs of inflation so far I think since
I'm running out of time off I'll skip
over that but it certainly hasn't shown
up yet what about this issue of making
promises in advance about policies years
in the future I think there's a clear
reason for the Fed to be trying to do
this as a substitute for interest rate
cuts and that's that to the extent that
it can give people a reason to expect
interest rates to remain low for years
into the future that should be a
substitute for further interest rate
cuts now in terms of its effect on
spending decisions so economic models
imply that the expected path of
short-term interest rates many years
into the future should be important
determinants of longer term asset prices
things like the value of the dollar
which are things that in turn should
have important effects on current
spending decisions so there's a clear
reason for what the Fed is doing to have
some relevance to current conditions I
think the idea of making an
unconditional promise to maintain
interest rates low until a fixed date
far in the future regardless of what
happens between now and then is
something that could indeed be unwise
that's not really what the Fed is done
they haven't made an unconditional
promise the mid-2015 date if you read
carefully is a current estimate of how
long they envision keeping the rates low
not an unconditional promise they talk
in that statement that I mentioned about
economic conditions
and how the length of time that rates
will remain low will depend on how the
economy is developing I think that in
fact does make more sense and I wish
they would move further in that
direction of clarifying what these
conditions are that we determine when
it's appropriate to raise rates but i
think they are moving in the right
direction by talking about it the way
they have finally just to say one thing
about the kind of issues that have come
up a lot in recently politically there
have been proposals to try to cut back
on the feds discretion of one kind or
another one proposal is change the
federal reserve act so that the feds
legislative mandate only refers to price
stability another proposal the
Republican platform calls for
establishing a commission to investigate
the usefulness of the gold standard
which would also be constraining
monetary policy I think it would be
perverse to be doing things of either of
these kind at the present moment I could
have imagined a few years ago when
inflation had been kept quite stable for
the previous 20 years and that had been
associated with a lot of stability of
the real economy one could imagine
people arguing and some people were
arguing that may be simply keeping
prices stable itself automatically
stabilizes the real economy too and
therefore just pursuing price stability
would be enough I think right now it
would be very hard to make that argument
because inflation has been kept very
stable like skipped over those slides
but inflation has been kept stable
inflation expectations have been
skeptical I don't think very many people
think the level of utilization of real
resources has therefore been fine so it
looks like that's not enough so this
would be a strange time to take out of
the Federal Reserve Act reference to the
goal of maintaining a high level of
employment another proposal in the
Republican platform is calling for
congressional audit of the Fed's
monetary policy decisions I think again
after what we've just been through
recent events have shown how complex the
issues are that the Fed has to deal with
I think that the advantages of allowing
neutral technical expertise to be
deployed rather than putting it all up
for debate in Congress the creation or
not of each of these special programs
many things had to be done quickly in
response to
rapidly changing events that it would be
particularly perverse to be thinking of
doing that right now I think maybe I
should stop there
right here and you're up
okay so um I'm going to talk a little
bit about what I think caused the crisis
and in understanding what caused the
crisis try to figure out what we should
do about it so uh as Michael so
carefully and cogently argued Ben
Bernanke the head of the Federal Reserve
took many extraordinary measures in the
middle of the crisis but since then has
settled into a strategy of keeping
interest rates low first the short rate
he reduced to zero and now by buying all
these assets that was increasing the
balance sheet and promising to keep the
short interest rate low for a long time
he's trying to get the long interest
rates to be low too so Ben Bernanke's a
good man I was in I was in school with
Ben Bernanke I know he's a good man he
dearly wants to put Americans back to
work he also wants to stabilize the
economy and he also wants to keep
inflation in check but one man can't do
everything he needs more policy tools
and he needs more help from the rest of
government and that's going to be my
theme now the problem today is basically
threefold there's the unemployment that
Mike Woodford talked about and showed
you there are too many people who can't
get loans not because they don't want to
pay the interest rate which is
incredibly low it's just that no one
will give them a loan even though
they're willing to pay the interest and
lastly there are too many people being
thrown out of their houses they're going
to be 8 million households thrown out of
their houses and foreclosures before the
aftermath of the crisis is over so why
didn't we do something directly about
the three problems that confront our
country instead of leaving everything to
Ben Bernanke and the Federal Reserve
what we should have forgiven i'm going
to say some of that household debt that
is the mortgage debt that wasn't going
to get paid back any way that we knew
wasn't going to get paid back anyway we
would have made the lenders better off
and the borrower's better off if we'd
forgiven part of it we should get people
to get more we should make it easier for
people to get more loans who are willing
to pay the interest rates and we should
put more p
to work directly say by improving our
infrastructure monetary policy can't
solve all these things by itself it's
too blunt and instrument so how did we
get into this mess you know it's an
exciting time to be a macroeconomist
this is the worst disaster that we've
had since the Great Depression and let's
face it macroeconomists didn't really
predict that this was going to happen
and we're still four or five years after
the crisis began we're still in the
throes of it so clearly it's an
opportunity if you're a macro economists
to develop a new theory or to revisit an
old theory that maybe was ignored so I'm
many people here in this audience of
partly of distinguished economists are
doing that very same thing so I'm going
to talk about you know one of my
theories but I think which I call the
leverage cycle so this is what I think
was the reason we got into this mess and
it basically works like this if you have
an asset that has a value here normally
people can borrow say forty or fifty
percent or sixty percent of the value of
the asset if you get a loan and use your
house as collateral maybe you could
borrow sixty or seventy percent of the
value of the house but then leverage
that is the loan to value goes up and up
and up and the effect of that borrowing
goes up on the same collateral that it
turns out pushes the price of the
collateral up so the price of the
clavicle goes up and now you can Brown
ninety-five percent of a higher value so
the amount of borrowing goes up once
because the ratio went up and then again
because the level of collateral goes up
and you're at a higher ratio the level
of growing is much higher and then what
happens when something goes wrong with
the collateral and the price falls below
the debt people are now under water
although so who loses money and who goes
bankrupt it's the people who borrowed
the most but they're the most optimistic
people keeping the prices up so the
prices fall some more then the lenders
get nervous and they say well we can't
make any more loans now no one else can
borrow and so of course there's no
demand and the price goes down even
further and so you're left with a huge
debt and very low asset values and that
gap is what I think has caused the long
aftermath too many households too many
businesses underwater
and so when the when the gap is too big
and it will never be paid that's where
some forgiveness I think can help
everybody so I regard this partly as
common sense but it's it can't be
totally common sense because the
implications of it still haven't been
accepted the Fed oughta have more tools
not less tools it ought to be able to
regulate leverage to prevent 95 or 97 or
ninety nine percent LTV on our borrowing
on households the country as a whole
should have had some sort of principal
forgiveness and we macroeconomists
should put endogenous leverage into our
models so the Fed ought to be doing more
I think not less it should be managing
levers which well as managing interest
rate since I always point out I can't
resist pointing this out you know this
is not an original idea Shakespeare
himself had this idea in the Merchant of
Venice it's all about a loan but you
know there was an interest rate
negotiated in the play but none of you
can remember what the interest rate was
you all remember the collateral the
pound of flesh the collateral and so he
knew it was more important than the
interest rate and secondly the rest of
the play is about forgiveness when the
boat sink and it doesn't appear that the
debt can be repaid the judge who's the
someone else in the sky says you no
mercy it helps him who give it in him
who receives it it makes everybody
better off if something totally
unexpected happens and so that's the
theme of what I'm going to be talking
about so bye-bye leverage I mean several
ways of saying the same thing the
loan-to-value we described before is one
way of saying leverage another way of
saying it is the down payment if you get
an 80% loan on a hundred dollar house
eighty dollar loan on a hundred dollar
house its twenty percent down payment
eighty percent you borrowed that's the
loan to value and the leverage is 521
because twenty dollars of cash got you a
hundred-dollar acid all the same thing
so in standard economic theory we talk a
lot about the interest rate supply and
demand determines the interest rate but
in that theory anyone who wants to
borrow at the interest rate can borrow
in my theory or which a number of people
are working on I shouldn't call it just
mine but in the theory the leverage site
go you you have another variable what's
the loan-to-value supposed to be and
it's a little paradoxical how can one
equation supply equals demand for a loan
determined the interest rate and
determine the loan to value but anyway
you'll have to read about the theory so
it turns out that in the theory
impatience determines the interest rate
and how worried the lenders are about
getting paid back determines the loan to
value if they're very nervous they're
not going to let you know if the asset
price might fluctuate then I can let you
borrow as much and loan to value below
also innovation always stretch as
collateral it makes a loan to value
higher if it's unchecked so people have
talked about leverage at least since
Shakespeare's time I'm sure Shakespeare
understood what every business person
understands that if you buy an asset
like a house with twenty dollars of cash
and it goes down one dollar you still
have to repay the eighty dollar loan so
you're left with 19's although the house
only went down one percent you lost one
out of twenty or five percent five times
leveraged so that's why leverage is
dangerous to banks but the the point of
the theory is that it's not just that
it's dangerous to the to the person
doing the leveraging if the banks are
too leveraged it also forces asset
prices up okay and that's the that's the
that's the main theme that when you can
borrow more on the house it pushes the
price of the house up now why should
that be because in general there are
lots of bar lots of potential buyers
some of them think the house is worth
more than others you can put them on a
vertical line the people who think you
want to pay the most at the top and the
people want to pay the less they're at
the bottom whatever the prices are
securities or houses or anything like
that there'll be some people the
marginal buyers who think the prices are
fair the people who have higher opinions
will become the buyers the people with
lower opinions will become the sellers
now as leverage goes up and you can
borrow more it requires fewer people to
buy all the available assets so the
marginal buyer goes up but the marginal
buyer is the guy who thinks the price is
fair so that means the price is going to
go up so even though no one changes
their opinion just by letting the
optimist be able to borrow more you're
going to inevitably push the price up so
that that's the basic idea of what
happens when there's low volatility and
the lenders aren't worried leverage goes
up the asset prices go up the Optimus
require acquire more and more the assets
and then something goes wrong and it
sets the stage for the crash so the
crash always has the same thing there's
bad news as I said that kills the most
optimistic buyers who borrowed so much
and then the lenders get nervous and
suddenly they won't lend as much so you
take the original set of buyers above
the original marginal buyer at the ex
they get wiped out because the price is
going down and then the remaining buyers
the people here are wiped out so who's
left to buy these people but now you
have to have many more of them because
they can no longer borrow because now
there's deleveraging you can't borrow
because the loan-to-value they didn't
get from a lender has gone way down so
you need far more people the marginal
buyer goes from here all the way down to
here and that's why the prices collapsed
so anyway so you get because of leverage
to high prices and then to low prices
and that leaves people in tremendous
debt I think that's what happened in our
crisis that's where we are now and
that's what we have to have dealt with
we should have been dealing with for the
last four years so this kind of thing I
think has happened repeatedly and so
this is a famous picture of Bob oops
sorry I skipped a few slugs is the
famous that green line represents the
housing index it's a Bob Shiller story
graph even it from 2002 its height in
2006 and the right axis it went from a
hundred two hundred ninety ninety
percent increase in six years incredible
housing boom why did it happen well he
says irrational exuberance that probably
played a big role but in addition to
that if you look at the loan to value of
the average loan taken out non
government loan for housing one from
fourteen percent down to two-point-seven
percent down that was the for the anyway
that was the down payment people were
making on loans 2.7% down to buy a house
that's what I think played a big role in
driving the housing prices up and this
drop in leverage is where to help bring
it down okay so if you look across
countries you take countries and look at
1997 the debt of households versus their
incomes and you look at country
like Ireland and 2007 see the dramatic
increase in debt of households to income
in some countries like Ireland in the UK
and Spain and Portugal its sword in
other countries like Germany and Japan
it didn't change at all even went down a
little bit and then if you look at what
happened to housing prices in all the
countries were debt soared the housing
prices soared in the countries like
Germany and Japan where debt didn't go
up housing prices didn't go up and if
you look at which country suffered as a
result of the crisis in the first couple
years it's the same countries whose who
had all the debt okay so the same is
true of securities as houses so the
crash at my view started you know what
was the scary news that started it off
it was people getting delinquent in just
a little bit delinquent so delinquencies
went from two percent in subprime loans
to five percent you might think of that
it's a tiny change it hardly matters but
when people go from two to five all of a
sudden it gets lenders worried it's
going to go higher and so they demanded
more down payments that's what I think
started the whole thing off okay so
where does that leave us now what should
we do about the leverage cycle well what
we should do i think is we should have
prevented this from happening by
curtailing leverage to begin with and if
we had if Ben Bernanke had more powers
at the beginning to curtail leverage
then we wouldn't have had this ninety
seven and a half percent loan-to-value
two percent down payments for a typical
mortgage loan housing prices would have
gotten that high other asset prices
wouldn't get that high perfect so uh so
that's the first thing that we should
have done we could have prevented this
crisis by curtailing leverage okay the
second thing we sorry in the middle of a
crisis what happens is everybody gets
nervous and so in the middle of the
crisis it's almost impossible to get a
loan so what should have happened is
what did happen the Fed stepped in and
made loans not necessarily at a lower
interest rate which they tried but also
making loans to people who didn't have
very good collateral so they changed the
loan to value it would have taken
incredible amount of collateral to get a
loan
and yet the Fed was willing to give and
the Treasury together we're willing to
make loans and these Mike referred to
these in these extraordinary times in
2008 and 2009 that they abandoned
immediately afterwards and said we'll
never do it again well I think they
abandoned it too soon and then the third
thing you have to do is in the aftermath
of the crisis when you've got this huge
gap in people under water you have to
forgive some of the debt and that's the
biggest mistake I think of the Obama
administration you know five years ago
the housing market started to collapse
six years ago so we've going to have
eight million people eventually kicked
out of their houses that's eight million
households that's 24 million people on
average if you have three in a household
it's an astonishing number of people now
it it uh what did the government try to
do of course the government recognized
the problem it tried to lower interest
rates on mortgages and to those people
who are having trouble making their
payments but as I wrote four years ago
with another law professor who was
trained here at the Yale Law School that
wasn't going to do the trick what we had
to do was forgive some of the debt now
if you take a typical subprime loan
that's for 160,000 and the house has
fallen to a hundred thousand must be
down to two or three then at a hundred
thousand alone 160 and a house is now
only worth a hundred thousand it's crazy
to think the person's going to pay in
fact if you throw him out of his house
as we're doing now with all these
millions of people the lender on average
got 40,000 back were 35,000 less than a
quarter of the money back the guy sits
in the house for three years not paying
his mortgage not paying his taxes not
fixing the house it's no wonder you get
so little back by throwing people out of
the house had you forgiven 160 down to
90 you might have gotten the 90 instead
of getting the 40 the homeowner could
have stayed there and the lender would
have been better off okay so it was all
predictable in late two thousand eight
that this was going to happen because
here if you see people who are far
enough underwater the rate at which they
were defaulting was seven percent a
month this is loan-to-value if you're
160 loan-to-value the faulting seven
percent per month if you're a subprime
borrower why would you pay if you owe so
much money you have a bad credit rating
to begin with you're not losing that
much by defaulting of course they were
going to default and was going to be
disastrous so writing down interest as
the government did just produced a bunch
of people who Rida fault it anyway so
this is 18 months after someone's
interest got reduced 18 months later you
know seventy percent or eighty percent
of them had Rida faulted the plan was
just writing down interest doesn't work
you have to do more so forgiveness I
think is the key it helps in the right
circumstances the lender and the
borrower and we have somehow a moral
aversion to forgiving which is hard to
understand the same problem occurs in
Europe where the troika is asking
countries that can't possibly pay the
entire debt to pretend that they're
going to pay it instead they're told if
you look like you're going to pay it
will lend you more money and put you in
more debt instead they should be told if
you do some reforms will promise in the
future to forgive some of your debt
it'll make will get more money in the
end and you'll be better off okay so the
final thing is what have we done we've
just lowered interest rates that's we've
left everything to Ben Bernanke and
we've practiced in Europe and here are
kind of fiscal austerity you know we
have to balance our budget so let's have
some austerity I think that austerity is
counterproductive this has been said by
Cannes and by Krugman in the new york
times over and over again but I'm but
but really what Krugman is saying is
that we should delay austerity now on
the crisis don't have austerity spend
now and then try and reduce the debt
later I'm saying I'm agreeing with
Krugman that too much austerity is a bad
thing but I want to go much further we
should have had some forgiveness and we
wouldn't have had this crisis so we've
cut the interest rate the short rate to
zero in 2008 Bernanke spending three or
four trillion dollars buying long bonds
to reduce the long interest rate yet we
still have low housing prices we still
have foreclosures we still have
borrowers who can't get loans and he may
be causing another crisis okay so if you
look at what's happened if the second to
last slide if you look what's happened
here are the prices of a bunch of assets
like high-yield you know all kinds of
mortgages Treasury bonds so starting at
two thousand eight december two thousand
eight they've all sword
you know by buying all these long assets
he's helping to force the price of every
acid up it's amazing you know if you're
an investor it's a great time to be an
investor in by all these soaring assets
with Bernanke and the Fed wishing the
price up the only thing that hasn't gone
up is housing that's the one at the
beginning with the same housing level as
we were after the crash we haven't got
housing to go up at all it's actually a
little down from where it was in
december two thousand eight okay so if
you look at people trying to get loans
sorry one more slaves look at people
trying to get loans and you see the
people with bad FICO scores they can't
get any loans compare the loans in 2006
to 2012 none of those people are getting
loans actually my fico score is in here
and you know it's amazing i can get a
loan and so what have we done what we're
doing by lowering interest rate I think
it's a kind of trickle-down economics
we're raising the price of everything if
you own stock the stock market's going
up if you owned high-yield bonds of
high-yield bonds are going up the rich
are getting richer because the Fed wants
them to be richer still spend a little
money that's trickle-down economics okay
when the because we the government now
has no longer has all these long loans
out that means people that we're in
danger it when the interest rates go up
that the government will have to pay
high interest rates and it was going to
hurt our budget if they're all long
loans their outstanding we didn't buy
them all back the interest rate would
have been locked in and lastly we may
have an unintended consequence of
causing a bubble like in high end so Ben
Bernanke's a good man he's trying the
best he can he deeply believes in what
he wants but he can't do it by himself
we should have helped him by putting
people to work and by forgiving
something we needed the Treasury in the
Congress to do that
that's your new house
okay thank you very much so you all are
very close observers of the election
you've listened closely to the debates
and what have you learned nothing you've
learned nothing at all about economic
policy you've learned more tonight than
you have watching six hours eight hours
nine hours of debate and that's because
the candidates have avoided all the
major issues that we're facing you've
heard two great presentations about
money and financial markets and a little
about fiscal and what I want to do is I
want to look primarily at fiscal policy
and I want to look forward now
incidentally it's not inevitable that
you can learn nothing from debates if
you go back to 1858 after all you
learned a lot in the lincoln-douglas
debates but it's true they were given
two hours not two minutes and that helps
a lot now what are the key economic
issues that we're facing we're facing
the fiscal cliff which I'll talk about
we're talking about the economic
recovery which to which John and Mike
have talked about we're facing a
long-term fiscal gap the issue of
controlling health costs and protecting
core government functions so those I'm
not going to talk about all of those in
detail but I don't want to talk about a
little of them each of them now let's
talk first about the fiscal cliff now
what's the fiscal cliff well there's a
little mixed metaphor here but
everything goes poof on December 31st
2012 your tax cuts expire your doctors
don't get paid unemployment the
unemployed loser betta their insurance
the military and government programs are
slashed now you might want to know what
exactly are the details well they're
pretty complicated and I won't go
through all of those but this is what's
involved in the fiscal cliff the
bush-era tax cuts 295 billion the
payroll tax cut 127 billion
expiring provisions 87 billion other tax
cuts 105 the Affordable Care Act 24
billion plus then you have in spending
you have the Budget Control Act which is
the sequestration which is the sword of
Damocles coming down on the military and
other programs you have more
unemployment insurance you have the doc
fix is in that any of other things as
well so a total of eight hundred and
nine billion dollars at an annual rate
that's about five percent of GDP that's
what will happen if we go off the fiscal
cliff now if that happens it's going to
be a real bad year at the beginning now
what are the contentious issues are
actually almost none the contentious
issues are the high income tax cuts that
did that the two candidates have been
debating and the taxes included in the
Affordable air of Affordable Care Act
that's a very small fraction that's
about ten percent of the total cliff so
we could we'd only go down ten percent
if with if everything else were passed
will we drive off the fiscal cliff I
don't know nobody I don't think anybody
wants to but nobody wanted world war one
nobody wanted world war two nobody
wanted to spend ten years in Iraq but
things happen and as our distinguished
chair and economics as he teaches the
students I hope many of you hear about
the game of chicken there's some bad
equilibrium economic recovery well Mike
talked about this at length so I'll just
say a couple words about it first it is
an incomplete recovery we're about a
half so that's the red line there is the
unemployment rate animal is on the left
are the unemployment rate in percent
that bluish band in the middle is what
is thought to be full employment as
calculated by the Congressional Budget
Office I put a little error band around
that because we don't know it for sure
so if you look from from the peak we're
a little less than
half of the way back from the peak in
2009 of the unemployment rate back to
what most macro economists would
consider full employment so we've made
some progress but we've got a long way
to go now Mike said use the phrase this
time is different I think it's a that's
important because there actually are
some important structural differences in
policy and the most important one I
think is that which he spent a long time
on is that monetary policy is
constrained by the zero bound at the
zero bound means that interest rates
cannot for all intents and purposes go
below zero they can maybe go to minus
point one percent but they can't go down
what would want them is minus two
percent or minus three percent everybody
but John who doesn't want them down that
low but many many macroeconomists do and
the Fed surely does now that the
government has two hands it has a
monetary hand and as a fiscal and and
we've been talking this morning or this
afternoon it's evening primarily about
the monitor and and I wanna talk about
the fiscal hand now the first important
part of fiscal policy was the stimulus
act and the stimulus actor he was the
stimulus at a cts because they were
stimulus under the Bush administration
before in 2008 and then that was the big
in stimulus package which has be not
been mentioned by the candidates we have
a 2009 now I think most economists
macroeconomists think that the stimulus
package helped in preventing a worse
economic down down turn so that if you
that if the stimulus package hadn't been
passed that that red line would have
been higher in 2009-2010 and 2011 and I
think if we look at what the constraints
that are operating on monetary policy we
need more not less fiscal stimulus we
need less austerity as John mentioned we
need actually a stimul we need fiscal
stimulus not to
who cut spending and increased taxes
today so if you actually listen to the
debates you would have been completely
misled because they had it backwards
nobody said we need more stimulus we
need another stimulus package but that's
what we need now what's confusing about
this I mean we have two eyes and two
hands but it's hard to chew gum and walk
and at the same time so what's very
confusing is that while the US needs
fiscal stimulus in the short run it's an
unsustainable fiscal position in the
long run and this is I'm going to talk
so this is two projections of the debt
GDP ratio these are by the Congressional
Budget Office and up till 2012 those are
appalled those are history and the 2
dashed lines are the two policies the
one is the what I call the cliff policy
is go off the cliff raise taxes cut
expenditures and just full speed ahead
greece greece and spain the kick-the-can
policy is this actually extend
everything extend all the tat extend all
the tax cuts extend the payroll tax
don't have this week sequestration let
the health programs go ahead that's
that's actually what's likely to happen
if anything happens is the kick-the-can
policy what you can see is that if you
follow the cliff policy even though you
have probably a pretty bad recession you
do reduce the debt GDP ratio but to kick
the can policy has an unsustainable dan
unsustainable path you can see that in a
few den that's a long way off obviously
but this is just looking at what the
implications are of our policy it's an
it's the debt-to-gdp ratio is off the
charts now the chairman instructed us to
give some geeky details so i have one
geeky slide today what is needed for
fiscal sustainability so there's a new
concept i would like to introduce to you
it's not a very deep concept but it's
called the primary surplus or deficit
and you take the budget and you take out
interest
you just just look at all spending
except interest in all revenues and
that's called the primary surplus or
primary in the present case primary
deficit now here's a really interesting
rule of thumb that you can remember
which is if you watch your debt GDP
ratio to be constant your primary budget
must be in balance I'm a very simple
rule it's a it's actually correct if you
actually look at the numbers when our
primary balance was but what a primary
budget was in balance and the debt GDP
ratio is stabilized so what we need is
we need to aim in the medium run for
primary balance or where are we well
this shows up to 2012 the history and it
was basically in balance until about two
thousand six and then went way south the
cliff policy which is above the line
actually has a primary surplus and the
kick the can policy has a continued
primary deficit so you need something in
between you don't you need somewhere in
between now what about taxes well this
is my favorite quote and if if I
whenever anyone says taxes this is what
i would say i would court justice holmes
who says taxes is what we are what we
pay for civilized society we can't have
the things we need the core functions of
government unless we pay for them so
it's like when you buy something you
need to pay a price in the prices taxes
and one of the things we have to
recognize is is we need to pay a little
more if we're going to have a civilized
society okay so what are the ingredients
for a fair and sustainable Fisk I have a
five-point plan on all right it's a
little different from the five-point
plans you've heard but just to give you
the kinds of things that are necessary
to close a fiscal gap this to get back
to primary surplus primary balance over
the next few years we're at about we
need about five percent of GDP to close
that gap
and here are five things each of us you
can get about one percent of GDP on one
is the expiration of the bush-era tax
cuts and the tax preferences for upper
incomes that's about a little less but
about close to one percent of GDP a
second one is now that everybody has
heard about climate change again they
heard about it in Katrina and now they
heard about it with Sandy so a carbon
tax of the kind that's been recommended
by many economists will raise about one
percent of GDP in revenues we need to
cap the growth of health care costs I'm
sorry folks but this is one where the
Republicans are right the Republicans
have a head but no hard and the
Democrats have a heart but no head and
on this one the you actually I'm going
to have to do something to cap the
growth of health care costs over the
next 10 to 20 years because it's going
to drive out every other core function
of government if you don't four things
we're going to need to raise the
retirement age on federal programs
primarily Social Security and but it
could be also in other programs as well
and you can get about another probably
not quite one percent with that and then
if we curb our military ambitions and
spending we can easily get another
percent from that so you take all those
and you get five percent of GDP now let
me end with the question i started with
which is where of all the grown-ups gone
well i think they're here but i think
they're huddled i think they're huddled
in the shelter against the hurricane now
i'm not talking about the hurricane the
natural hurricane i'm talking about a
man-made hurricane of the money that's
sweeping through our economy the money
the business interests the spending of
the super rich individual that's blowing
through the country you have to ask
yourself why is it that the u.s.
government which is the largest economic
entity on earth with spending twenty
percent of the size of our economy
that's about three trillion dollars a
year cannot plan activities even
two months ahead here we are on November
first and we don't know what our tax
rates are going to be on january first
we don't know what our spending is going
to be our doctors don't know whether
they're going to be paid or not the
military cannot plan that's no way to
run a country and I think we need to ask
ourselves how we're going to improve
that thanks
when it takes too much time are we yeah
we're on okay so well thank you all for
those presentations i thought i'd ask
the other panelists for some reaction to
the to the those opening remarks so Bob
Shiller you have any particular
reactions well it's in a 5-minute a
summary this is how Mike Woodford began
with a presentation of the enormity of
the problem we are in the biggest
economic crisis since the Great
Depression we are recovering supposedly
the recession ended in 2009 but it's a
very slow recovery and our gross
domestic product is way below the track
it's a rare event Great Depression was a
big event it was 70 years ago it could
get worse the IMF in its latest global
financial stability report said that the
the world financial system is very
fragile and they use the word alarming
for the situation now I'm not saying I
know what's going to happen next but
what is driving a lot of talk in this
election campaign is what's going wrong
and how do we get some kind of
leadership to get us out of that
unfortunately I don't know that we have
clear answers to the various proposals
that are speakers told seem on
unsatisfying to people well we're in a
situation like that which franklin
roosevelt described in his in his
inaugural address of fear and
uncertainty and that as Roosevelt said
the only thing to fear is fear itself so
we're in a vicious cycle where people
are not spending and businesses are not
investing enough and it's worldwide
we're seeing Asia slow down we see
Europe in a recession what do we do
about that and that is a fundamental
problem that the debaters did not
address nothing all three presenters
here did a great job of bringing in some
of the economics it's very complicated i
don't know if you got all that was just
presented in contrast the candidates
don't seem to have any connection to
anything that was said here i thought
what i did in preparation for this is I
I I took all for today's the three
presidential debates and the vp debate
put them in one file and I searched the
word jobs came up a hundred and
sixty-one times the word economy came up
a hundred and one times no economist was
ever mentioned there was no mention of
Ben Bernanke no mention of the Federal
Reserve in any of the four debates
though there was no mention of the
commercial paper funding facility
no mention of multipliers and I'm sorry
there was one mention of leverage and
John Mitt Romney you missed it Mitt
Romney is your man because he said he
wants to eliminate dodd-frank and
replace it with leverage requirements so
so those are the issues so what what
this seems to be about is that Romney is
coming forth and saying that there's a
fundamental confidence problem or
uncertainty problem and we need a
completely different it's a revolution
that he's arguing we need to move to a
different kind of government which is
much smaller that frees up individual
initiative that relies on small
businesses the idea being that somehow
this whole problem was caused by the
government interfering interfering with
the free market economy that is the same
argument that was used by alf landon in
1936 when he tried to steal the
presidency away from roosevelt now
fortunately at that election the economy
in the November of 36 was improving
nicely just a matter of months later we
had a downturn and Landon would have
been probably elected but but still the
the doubts visit persisted we had one
great revolutionary thinker in the Great
Depression John Maynard Keynes who by
the way is never ever mentioned by
either side in this debate anyway I
don't just say I I don't have enough
time to present this well but
who are we voting for if we vote for
Obama vs Romney in terms of economic
policy this is the big issue and neither
of them is an economist how could they
possibly come up with a solution to
these deep problems well it's their
advisors and their advisers are standing
in the background rather quietly nor we
have Greg Mankiw we have Kevin Hassett
on the Romney side Kevin Hassett is
author of the book down 36,000 which he
wrote in two thousand predicting an
enormous stock market boom on the Obama
side we don't have Larry Summers anymore
and we don't have christina roman the
chief economic advisor right now is Gene
Sperling and i'm proud to say he is a
graduate of the Yale Law School where we
are and he is a smart guy he has a book
called the pro-growth progressive it's a
wonderful book nobody reads it but in a
sense the public isn't interested in
legislation that might provide produce a
solution but i think obama has has done
it assembled a good team now they're not
inspired like Cannes was to find a deep
sand major solution to this problem but
I'll just close by just going through
some things in the American Jobs Act
which was the last major piece of
legislation proposed by Obama and
introduced into Congress a year ago and
I and I think gene sperling hands are
all over this because I can I read his
book and I see it's not just Gene
Sperling it has innovative ideas in it I
should also give another plug to
remember Lori klett sir was here at the
Yale Economics Department in 2001 she
proposed with Robert light on a program
of wage insurance that would help
protect workers against
having to take a job at a lower wage
this would be the confidence restoring
thing that SAT dormant for a decade and
then Gene Sperling or President Obama or
someone there put it into this
legislation they put into the
legislation and America American
infrastructure financing Authority none
of this has happened by the way because
the Republicans shut this down but the
aif I would be a government agency that
would facilitate infrastructure
investment Rose highways harbors global
warming prevention things a whole list
of these thing and it would not just be
government it would be public-private
partnerships it's a great idea it
actually resembles an idea that our own
martin shubik has been talking about for
some years and it goes back further than
further than that but it's going at the
basic infrastructure problems what else
soon what else did the Act ask for it
asks for money to pay for jobs for
veterans jobs for teachers hire back the
teachers a first responder stimulus
which would be hiring back the fireman
and the policeman that we've laid off
this is an absurd situation because of
the weak economy we lay off these people
and then it only makes it economy worse
it has something called pathways to work
Bridge to work people are losing skills
because they're unemployed for such a
long time so we want to subsidize them
being at least partly in the labor force
so it doesn't get worse and worse taken
together done the final step this is
what killed the act
Obama wanted to raise taxes on the top
5% it was half of one person I'm sorry
incomes over a million by five percent
and that would have paid for the whole
thing and it would be a balanced budget
act that did not raise the deficit so it
was such a beautiful maybe it was too
small but it's such a beautiful piece of
legislation well not mike Ward ferd has
written the paper about multipliers and
I think you can pure having read your
paper that a balanced budget stimulus
works so we had an act entered into
Congress that would have not worsened
the deficit that would have gotten all
of these things done it wouldn't have
been enough to bring us out but it would
have done a lot so in that sense I'm
thinking that this whole idea that Obama
has no plan is not really true I mean we
saw it it's just that nobody wants to
read an act introduced into Congress
it's not well written for the general
reader but there is an obama plan and i
think personally I am has a higher
probability of having some success then
the kind of nebulous idea that Romney is
proposing that lowering taxes on
businesses will free up free enterprise
that no one knows for sure but my
judgment call is that we have a except
for you with your leverage plan which is
not in these at not on the act I'll stop
them
thank you
so all those events he is going to now
tell us why we're all focused on the
wrong problem okay all right so I think
everybody's getting a little tired here
so let me lighten it up to you and just
try to explain what happened here so we
have just imagined would have a very
sick individual which is the US economy
and we have a village chief which is the
president 11 to convince a group of the
doctors this gentleman circle I look
like a group of distinguished doctors
but there's one problem economists are
much worse than doctors in trying to
understand what's going on with the
patient so let me explain I think what
are the what the suggestions are of some
of the doctors here so John Jenna
coppice is saying well let's read the
Shakespeare to this very sick individual
bill Nordhaus I said well let's give him
a lot of coffee it's going to be good
stimulus for the individual Mike
Woodford the famous New York doctor
comes with his very fancy briefcase and
said well let's do MRI and we'll try to
detect what's wrong with this what this
in GV don't try to figure out what to do
and Bob Shiller said well there is a
plan yeah but since we don't know that
well about how the economy operates
maybe we should ask the question maybe
it's the food medicine that all of us
are proposing here is what is killing or
not killing or at least making this very
sick individual the US economy lr sick
all right so what do I propose instead
of the voodoo medicine I proposed free
air and vigorous exercise routine so
what does this mean it means that
perhaps we should just focus not on the
all of the details we have talked here
about that we should focus instead on
economic growth now let me give you some
numbers we should jot it down while
listening to this distinguished Buddha
doctors so the if you look at the
pre-crisis trend from 1960 07 the growth
of the economy was plus three point six
percent okay so let's look at the
recovery was anemic recovery the patient
is sick
from the third quarter of oh nine to the
third quarter of 11 so it was 2.1
percent so you say well three-point-six
percent 1.5% were three-point-six
percent 2.1 percent it's only one point
five percent difference is it a really
big deal one-point-five percent of
growth per year just think about this
number for a second doesn't seem like a
big deal so only one point five percent
let me give you some numbers for this
over five years the cumulative
difference if the economy grows at three
point six percent versus 2.1 percent is
twenty-three percent of GDP this is of
the order of magnitude of what has
happened with during the Great
Depression the loss of the gdp let's
look over ten years over ten years the
difference of 1.5% of growth per year
cumulatively so if you count how much
the economy makes under this two
scenarios will be ninety-seven percent
of GDP just think about this nine to
seven percent of GDP so just again to
give you some numbers I mean these are
all abstract big numbers and the
gentlemen look and how could you get
this number it's the cumulative is the
cumulative difference so think about the
u.s. combined total debt at sixteen
trillion dollars so it's about the same
order of magnitude ninety-seven percent
of Los gdp is 6.1 times more than total
healthcare spending in the US now
private and public it's 21 times defense
budget it's 15 times the total private
and public educational spending and
finally well like Yale we sit here at
Yale for this amount of money we can
build 751 endowments of Yale if we find
750 extra Rick leggins so those are just
giant numbers in terms of per person for
a family of four it's 185 thousand
dollars so that's what a difference of
1.5% of growth over ten years is all
right so
what should I what should I say what
should we do I think that I wouldn't
just point out to some of the issues
which came up which may have been making
this anemic patient even sicker so what
do we have what are the strong headwinds
which will generate this significant
slowdown of growth well death we all
know from economic research and I teach
to us on the gentleman in my class were
sitting there so that if you have a data
both ninety percent of GDP you're
hitting the redline over which the
advanced economies get a slowdown of
growth of one percent of GDP per year
taxes we all know that increase in taxes
are hugely distortionary not over
short-term perhaps not over some
individual perhaps but let me just give
you some numbers better rattling
estimate that one percent average
increase increase in the average
marginal tax rate minus point six
percent of gdp for all monomer the
person who have mentioned as crystorama
who was an economic advisor for
president obama estimate that increase
of taxes by one percent is minus three
percent of gdp a recent paper by trabant
and oleg show that if the US were to
move to the top of the Laffer curve and
that's not a laughing matter it's going
to be minus twenty-seven percent of gdp
all right we'll have to increase the
access probably to cut down that and
this will lead to serious headwinds for
the US economy over-regulation how can
we say you know regulation is not sure
look I've seen during this crisis that
the regulation perhaps was one of the
causes of the problem but the pendulum
is swinging to the other side maybe we
are to decide over the over-regulation
there is some recent economic research
that shows that if you chop off across
countries the three of the worst crisis
you would decrease economic growth by
point thirty three percent it's again
this little numbers add up okay so let's
look at the quality of US economic
policy I think the bill nor house after
the right
we are seeing unprecedented uncertainty
with what is going to happen with the US
economic policy recent research
estimates that increase of the
uncertainty in the US economic policy
from 2007-2009 cause three-point-two
percent loss of gdp but finally and this
is probably what worries me importantly
or what is more than even the other the
other things about what I have said is
that I think what we're seeing during
this crisis one of the casualties of
this crisis is going to be the way how
the US economy operates I think we're
moving to the state where we have much
more state intervention where we think
that state intervention is good and
again so one of the nicest papers I've
seen recently which is by by somebody
comes from Northwestern and UCLA this
shows that this changes in the beliefs
of what the markets or state
interventions are good are extremely lon
lon running so what do I seen is that
unfortunately I think that the US is
going to look more and more and more
like Europe have we seen something like
this have we seen the confluence of
these factors happening somewhere else
or am I just again talking about some
voodoo economics but have a laboratory
for this and the perfect laboratory is
Japan in Japan we have seen the last
decade of growth in the 1990s and the
two thousands also was not a very
cheerful decade for for Japan economy so
what I'm afraid of is that by giving the
wrong medicine all of us actually here
are unfortunately going to make our US
economy look more and more like very
anemic and very slow growing patient and
we're going to lose educated growth
for open up anyone want to respond to
dr. sowinski remedies will let the
audience do it okay it's a matter of
degrees some is we don't want to go too
far to either extreme right we need
government infrastructure support and so
the question is how do you know where to
move this is a good point so and you
certainly nobody saying we should not
have government and in fact one of the
things that I think I agree when very
few things I agree with President 11 is
that perhaps in the long run the
investment in infrastructure is going to
pay off its going to have a quite a high
fiscal multiplier however over the short
term I just don't see the evidence that
the fiscal multiplier on infrastructure
investment disguise so there is a recent
paper by the dukan Wilson which we
actually talked about in our class for
those who were not in their hands heads
is that in the short run unfortunately
the effect is not as large as in the
long run so government certainly is
needed but maybe we are having too much
government and all of us here saying the
same thing I'll just throw one thing and
I mean I think the evidence on
multipliers that'sthat's inferred from a
long period of history is not very
relevant to the current situation
because we're in a hugely leveraged
economy with a huge overhang of debt and
the effects of God either tax cuts or
spending on / on consumer behavior are
going to be different when you're
sitting there with a mountain of debt
then when you're not and and so you know
for example a small tax cut like the
payroll tax cut at virtually no
multiplier because because people paid
down debt rather than the back to pay
down debt to a far greater degree five
percent of GDP per year it was the
deleveraging the consumer sector at a
time when they're getting this small
payroll tax cut so you know I'm not
persuaded that that job creating
multipliers are zero I think they're
quite positive actually absolutely works
I think you are making a very good point
is which is the phone perhaps we are in
the unprecedented time but what we have
for our laboratory we have we have
variety of models where we can see what
would happen counterfactual what would
happen during the time when the leverage
is high and I think it's very difficult
unless you really you know jump
backwards under all kinds of hoops to
get very large very large multipliers
certainly there is some research which
has a large multipliers but if I take
your point of the face value I would err
on the side we probably don't know so
given that we don't know should we
really now stimulate this patient we I
guess most of us would are you we better
be doing something now rather than
nothing okay we're gonna open it up to
questions from the floor and as I
mentioned you could line up on either
side yes so I have an observation in a
question in the initial graphs that
Professor Woodford showed I was struck
by the fact that the upward slope of
both the employment line and the output
line were about the same in in the last
three or four years as they were in the
period before they had just dropped
because of the recession that's my
observations of thought that was
interesting but I'm also wondering is
there a correlation between the decrease
in manufacturing employment from 1970
the 2010 which I understand is dropped
about thirty four percent so is it is
there a correlation between that
reduction in manufacturing employment
and the slow recovery anybody want to
answer that does the fact that we have
less manufacturing in the GDP today mean
that recovery slower I think that's the
other way
the question there's the theory that
manufacturing is more cyclical but can
wear more of a service economy and so it
should be the economy should be more
stable now right the part of the economy
that suffered the most is the part of
the economy that's down the most is
housing construction and construction in
general that's where the most
unemployment is that's the category with
the biggest drop in in expenditure and i
know that's a little bit like
manufacturing so I don't know that
having more the economy dependent on
that I think we'd be in worse shape not
better shape just add something so about
some some misconceptions I think here so
if you'll look that's a very good
question so in fact if you look at the
unemployment now it's it also at the
same time is correlated to the
polarization of the second so it looks
like and then there is some evidence
supporting that that a huge chunk of
this lingering unemployment is coming
from them from the middle of the
distribution it's not from the very high
skilled workers it's not from the very
low skilled workers working for the non
out sort and non of horrible not
outsourcing jobs so it's it's this
middle of the of the of the distribution
which is being heard the most and
probably know the loss of the
manufacturing you ask has something to
do with it yeah as a comment on the
connection you know I doubt that it's
the the reduction in the size of the
manufacturing sector that's that's
responsible i mean if one asks what the
consequences of that has been for the
stability of the US economy i would
point out that if you look at the 20
years before the recent crisis the
volatility of gdp growth was notably low
compared to previous decades when
manufacturing was a bigger sector i
think you could easily argue that the
shift toward a smaller manufacturing
sector might have been one of the
reasons that the volatility of the
economy had had in fact become lower now
that obviously didn't prevent the kind
of thing from happening that just
happened but if you ask me
was it about the changes in the US
economy that made it possible to have
the kind of deep and also difficult to
recover from crisis it's just occurred i
would think there's another trend that's
arguably connected with it and that was
the progressive deregulation of the
financial sector that had also been
going on in recent decades and that i
think has a fair amount to do with the
creating the possibility of what's just
happened to us but i think you know
there's no connection i see at least
between that and the decline of
manufacturing are just 2 comments one is
that if you look at that the long-term
development trends of mature high-income
economies well would you first see is
the decline of agriculture so for
example agriculture is down to about one
percent of our economy now and then you
see the second trend after that is first
the growth of manufacturing and then the
decline of manufacturing the share of
employment and that's that's a trend in
all high-income economies the other
point I want to make is we we have a
very misleading image of what
manufacturing is maybe from the pictures
of people striking the great iconic
pictures but the largest single job in
manufacturing is chasing inventories and
so I think we need to really change our
view about what manufacturing is
manufacturing is design manufacturing is
things like Apple Apple if you take your
ipod ipod is a beautiful very highly
profitable device but it's actually very
little of it it's really made in the
sense of physical sense in the United
States it's made in probably with parts
from 70 countries it benefits from a
great free trade zone and we have the
distinct advantage of living off the
royalties from that but that is
manufacturing but it's not our
traditional image of manufacturing yes
for certain question for professor
nordhaus um and I hate to be the the
staunch Democrat and pick on the one
thing where you said the Republicans had
it right but I'm I'm wondering where
you're seeing this you said something
about how the Republicans are more
serious now about controlling health
care costs and that's something that we
need to do and and you know from my
perception of the debate you know maybe
that was you know I think that maybe was
true a couple decades ago maybe during
the Clinton administration that the you
know that historically the Democrats
were more concerned with expanding
access expanding coverage and the
Republicans were more concerned with
constraining costs but it seems to me
that in the last few years the debate
about Obamacare has been basically all
that it has basically been the Democrats
who have been serious yes more about
expanding coverage but also about
reining in costs and the Republicans
have been the ones who were crying death
panels the moment you know there was any
suggestion that we would use
evidence-based standards of care and so
forth and you know right now Mitt Romney
as you know as far as as far as i know i
mean he's going around saying that that
we should they be wants to repeal
obamacare but keep the things that would
basically expand access like the not
excluding people for pre-existing
conditions and so forth but get rid of
all these things that that would do
something to curb costs so so i'm
wondering where you're seeing right now
you know the the Republican side being
more concerned with with cutting costs
it seems to me that what they're more
concerned with in their rhetoric in the
last few years has been basically
preserving the pre-obamacare status quo
so just to repeat what i said i will
repeat what i said i'll put in an
alternative language i actually was not
i mean if you if you listen to the
debates there's actually been no
informed
aight about the Affordable Care Act the
president actually has barely defended
it and it's the attacks of agri not
about the Affordable Care Act itself
it's about the Medicare it's about the
effect on reimbursements from Medicare
so it's actually not about the
Affordable Care Act at all what I was
saying was that the Affordable Care Act
actually does not can end a legislation
and the proposals do not deal with a
long-term fiscal impacts of health care
paid for the federal government roughly
if you look at health care over the next
25 years the share of GDP going to
health finance by the federal government
is projected to go up by five percent of
GDP so virtually all the fiscal the
increase in the primary deficit is due
to increased spending on federal health
programs what I was saying is there is
nothing in the Affordable not that
there's nothing there's nothing credible
in the Affordable Care Act and there
been no serious proposals by the
Democrats to deal with that now the
Republicans by contrast have they have a
very simple program they just cut the
programs out they send Medicaid back to
the states as a block grant which
basically will allow it to wither and
die and on Medicare they have a plan
which is basically a would turn it into
a defined benefit plan which is a plan
it has no public support it will not get
through Congress and it doesn't deal
with the problem of rising costs other
than by putting it on individuals so I
just want to be clear what I'm saying
the problem is that you could say
neither of them has realistic ways of
dealing with the long-term fiscal
impacts of the health care I think that
is one it's a very difficult issue we
haven't talked about the substance there
is a very difficult issue to solve but I
think neither of the groups have solved
in a way that both is politically
feasible
and intellectually accurate my question
is for michael woodford so earlier you
had said that the fed keeping its policy
rate between zero and a quarter of the
lower bound won't necessarily lead to
hyperinflation because other interest
rates were already low I think you
mentioned the money markets I say the
high reserves are not producing
inflationary pressures given these other
factors right so I was wondering if you
could elaborate on that because I have
always thought of maybe I confuse your
point but I had always thought of the
Fed Funds rate as sort of the benchmark
for other rates and as the feds way of
guiding other interest rates and so this
is just sort of a new way of I've never
thought about the Fed Funds rating this
way so I was hoping you could sort of
elaborate on that point a bit the
question I what I was talking about was
the question of whether these unusually
large level of bank reserves were going
to be we're going to be inflationary or
not and that depends on whether or not
there's some problem with getting the
banks to be willing to hold them and
what I pointed out was that before the
very unusual situation that we've been
in the last few years ordinarily there's
a substantial opportunity cost to
holding reserves therefore banks are
only willing to hold a very small level
determined by their need for clearing
balances and things of that kind and
given this willingness to only hold a
small level even increasing them a
little bit causes substantial changes in
financial conditions because they have
to occur to restore the balance between
supply and demand that's currently not
operative in this situation where the
interest being paid on the reserves and
that's not the federal funds rate it's
the interest that the Fed pays the banks
for for holding reserves is currently at
25 basis points not very high but fairly
high compared to other short-term
interest rates that's a very different
situation than in the past and I was
pointing out that under those
circumstances very large reserve
balances aren't inflationary in the
future one could imagine
that other interest rates are going to
have to go up to not be inflationary not
because the federal funds rate doesn't
determine them but because the federal
funds rate itself might have to go up to
head off inflation under other
conditions than the ones that were in
right now but I was saying that even
then you could still have very large
reserve balances consistent with that it
would simply mean paying interest on the
reserve balances that are commensurate
with the extent to which you're trying
to raise other interest rates yes I have
a question for professor John
giannakopoulos I think it's a brilliant
idea to just write down the principles
for those for underwater but I'm just
curious about if you think or how do we
how should we just pin down the extent
to which we cut down the principal and
in addition to that should we just cut
down the principal for everybody or
should we just cut down the principal
for those who are dip it in water and
the final question is if we cut down the
principles for those whose houses are in
water would it be a negative incentive
for those who have been cautious about
purchasing decisions who so that they
are not in there not under water yeah
thank you it's good to clarify this so
forgiving sounds like it's bound to get
you into trouble and be bad for the
lender or create some bad incentive but
what I was suggesting I don't think
creates any bad incentives and is good
for the lender so imagine that you are a
subprime lender the guys who you lent to
his house is down to a hundred thousand
even though he owes you one hundred
sixty thousand he has a terrible credit
rating he's proud he's almost surely not
going to pay eventually he's going to
realize that he can't make the payments
and he's going to stop paying they were
defaulting at seven percent a month so
you could extrapolate forward by a year
or two and realized they were almost all
going to default so if you know that by
telling him okay we're going to throw
you out of the house you can't just
throw him out the next day he it takes a
long time to get him out of the house in
the end
you a fact not a conjecture of fact the
subprime lenders got less than
twenty-five percent back of the loans
when they threw people out of their
houses 25% effect was closer to twenty
percent and already in 2008 the market
understood that they were going to get
less than twenty-five percent back the
market you can see by traded securities
the market understood they get less than
twenty-five percent back so you could
make more money for the lender by saying
will reduce so how much did you reduce
it to you should reduce it to just below
the how what the house is worth that
takes a lot of effort you have to go and
sort of figure out how much could the
guy sell the house for if he had to sell
it now so if he could sell it for about
a hundred you reduce it to 90 now he's
got a good incentive to try and pay the
90 because he can either sell the house
and make 10 or it's actually he's got he
owns something so it would help the
lender and help the borrower it doesn't
I wouldn't forgive the debt for people
who already defaulted the idea was to
forgive the debt for people who were
still current but you knew we're going
to eventually give up and default so you
don't create any incentive for bad
behavior because you're forgiving them
before they've done anything bad before
Greece does something horrible and just
says forget it we're giving up we're
gonna pay nothing before you get to that
point you have to tell them we'll
forgive something if you don't you're
going to get to the point where they
just give up and pay nothing then
instead of getting you know half of 350
million euros that's 175 million you
might get nothing so it can sometimes
curiously help the lender to forgive
part of the debt as well as the borrower
and of course they would have a
tremendous effect on the economy I don't
think it would make people less likely
to lend as Bob Shiller always likes to
point out at this point he says he
proposed a mortgage a long time ago
which had the feature that if the
Shiller index of housing went down then
some of the debt would be automatically
forgiven so that way you know because
it's better for the lender to do it you
don't have a complicated negotiation
about how to do it so I think it
wouldn't it would make the market thrive
more not less we've come to a time where
it's too late now they've all Betty
ready when so many people thrown out of
their houses and the people left have
not paid for two years now you create a
problem if you reward them okay and
lastly
because your neighbor gets in step
reduced and you don't that doesn't mean
you have to be angry you'll be glad to
know that your next door neighbor's
house isn't going to be ruined and your
house will be worth more even though you
don't get your debt forgiven because you
didn't take out any debt yes hi I'm
curious about professor Nord houses
five-point plan I was wondering why
favor letting the bush tax cuts expire
as opposed to more like a like a bowl
simply Nyes like broadening the base
revenue-raising reform because carbon
tax ins actually seem politically
feasible so I wasn't really sure that
was the issue or if you just don't
really like the the research like
precious minutes keep talking about
marginal tax rates if you don't leases
as much of the factor in terms of
economic growth I'm not quite sure I
understood so what I was talking about
was the upper income it's basically the
similar to what Obama has proposed the
last two rounds which has let the higher
income tax cuts expire extend the lower
income tax cuts just to be clear that's
a lot easier than base brought in a
unity we've had one time in my lifetime
when we've had any success in broadening
the tax base in the 86 tax reform it's
just very very difficult if you want to
just remember what's in their mortgage
interest state local taxes employer
financed health raise your hand if you
want if you're willing to sacrifice
those please for our for what are
putative Lee lower rates so but it
actually is feasible and it on the
bargaining table and possible to let the
upper income tax cuts expire like a
brief follow-up so do you think carbon
taxes are feasible alright you know if
you'd asked me that you would never have
asked me that 20 years ago because you
probably wouldn't have heard of it you
would probably not wouldn't have asked
to ten years ago because it wasn't on
the agenda it's actually on the agenda
to the extent when people begin to think
seriously about climate change and what
kinds of instruments are available they
could compare something simple like a
carbon tax which will raise a lot of
revenue and have the kinds of fiscal
impacts I talked about or they could
have a 900-page bill like the
house-passed bill which has slices of
allocations of permits to every every
group you can think of in a few you
couldn't think of I think it's it's
neither it's cleaner it raises revenue
it doesn't have the kinds of
implications for bureaucracy it's
something that it's actually interesting
if you look at conservative economists
so the mank use the Philistines the
Baskins advisors to republican
presidents they actually agree with the
people who are present they say if
you're going to do something that's the
way to do it so i actually think at some
point if you get the Wyoming senator off
of the out of the room because the
Wyoming senators never been greedy to
attacks it son Cole if you get the
Wyoming center out of the room it's
something that actually would have broad
consensus among economists and at the
point when global warming is taken
seriously it's clearly the best way to
proceed so is it is it going to happen
this year maybe over the next five years
don't bet against it very optimistic yes
my questions for a professor
giannakopoulos you made the case that
forgiveness of mortgages it's good for
lenders and I'm inclined to believe you
you made a good case for it but I guess
if that's true why didn't we see lenders
forgive the mortgages and I guess maybe
forgive my knowledge about the mortgage
market but if they didn't have that
power would it be possible if instead of
forgiving if instead of the federal
government for giving all the mortgages
if they just gave the lenders the power
to do so okay that's another very good
question so I was talking about subprime
mortgages that's that's where the crisis
began and that's where all the first
defaulters were and those are the people
who have are most likely to default
because they they don't have a
rating to defend so they if their way
underwater they have every incentive to
walk away from the loan they're almost
never chased down and their bank
accounts you know taken or something
like that they just leave and they you
know so the reason why the loan wasn't
forgiven none of the deaths were
forgiven is because subprime loans are
pooled they're almost all they're not
given just by banks their pooled
together you know about the subprime
pooling and then the payments that the
homeowners make or divided up among
bondholders so in order to forgive the
debt you would have had to get all the
bondholders to come together and agree
and say let's forgive the debt now the
person had the power to forgive the debt
was the so-called servicer that was the
guy who sends the bills out collects the
money and divides it up among the
servicers but that guy doesn't own the
bonds those are mostly big banks and
they had nothing to gain by forgiving
principle they wouldn't make any effect
if they cut the principal in half they
lose half their fee in order to cut the
principal down to the right number the
last guy asked me you have to know what
the house is now worth you have to send
sewn on the ground to visit the house
and to appraise it to figure out what
it's worth it's a big expense for them
to do they're getting nothing out of it
so the op-ed I wrote in 2008 was the
servicers have no incentive to write
down the principle it's not to their
benefit and the bondholders who would
like to get together to do it don't know
each other are they can't find each
other so you need someone to intervene
like the government and say okay the
servicers are not acting as good agents
of the bondholders and so what we have
to do is replace them as agents not take
away any their income just turn over the
modification decision to government
agents and the government job would be
make the modification that makes the
most money as possible for the lender
for the pool as a whole and so I think
they would have written down principal a
lot but no one had the incentive to do
it so it was a consensus problem a
coordination problem that's what
government is for to bring together
people don't know you know who can't
coordinate because they don't know each
other are there was a consortium of 19
hedge funds that own these bonds that
asked Congress to write down a principal
so many of the bondholders want to see
this
done it's not some crazy idea many of
the you know greedy in hedge funds with
the most to gain by getting their money
they wanted to see the debt forgiven
exactly a lot simpler now because a lot
of these very same bonds are now owned
by either Fannie Mae or Freddie Mac or
the Federal Reserve it be simpler now
but it's sort of too late now
unfortunately because so many people are
already you know a few years not paying
their mortgage it's a lot more difficult
to forgive their debt and not cause a
moral hazard problem you know encourage
people to you know I was recommending it
when you wouldn't you would have you'd
forgive people who hadn't done anything
wrong they kept their promises up till
then now you have to forgive people
who've given up two years ago and it's a
more complicated situation it still
might be a good idea but it's more
complicated now one over here my dress
was also for professor giannakopoulos um
so you talked about how Bernanke needs
more power with being able to control
leverage and stuff I was just wondering
if you could explain that a little more
like we have a kind of good idea of what
would cause what causes in interest
rates to go up and down I was wondering
what sorts of things would cause him to
change the leverage or if it would just
be a fixed ceiling or if you could
expand on that okay so um I was at the
Federal Reserve Jackson Hole a couple
years ago making this case and someone
asked me the very same question how
would you decide when it's time to limit
leverage and then Stan Fischer who had
been before a famous professor at MIT
who everyone here knows who's now the
head of the bank of israel he jumped up
and he said housing prices in Israel
took off I was scared that there was a
terrible bubble I was going to cause a
calamity in Israel so I simply forbade
any bank in Israel for making a loan at
more than 60 LTV that's sixty percent
LTV that's a very stark and low number
maybe I should have made it seventy
instead of 60 but I knew something was
wrong the leverage was getting too high
and the housing prices were getting too
high
I thought people were going to be in
danger and so I I put a stop to it and
so it's hard to get exactly the right
number but when you see the kind of
housing surge that Bob showa pointed out
ninety percent in six years and you see
the down payments go from you know
fourteen percent on average to
two-point-seven percent on average it's
clear that they've gotten out of hand
and somebody should have intervened so
the Federal Reserve didn't have the
power to intervene and secondly they
didn't know the numbers so it turns out
that the federal reserve was not at that
time following down payments house by
house now they know all those numbers
but back then they'd even know the
numbers it wasn't regarded as an
important variable to keep track of now
obviously they keep track of it tell you
one more story so trichet was at this
meeting the head of the ECB and he said
it's great we should definitely control
leverage but the Federal Reserve or the
Central Bank of Europe shouldn't be in
charge of it it should be another agency
that controls leverage and the bank
should stick to interest rates and I
said that reminds me a little bit of the
old Russia where you had one Bureau in
charge of prices and the other Bureau in
charge of setting quantities would it be
better if you had them together in one
Bureau and Bernanke said eventually the
Fed is going to do it we're just not
ready for it yet so do you think there's
a leverage that should never go above no
I think it depends on what's happening
to asset prices if the economy is very
depressed now I think that the Fed
should intervene to try and increase
leverage however it can and if things
are booming that's the time when it
should try to crack a leverage so you
don't think that they're like 97% you
think is acceptable at some at some
point in time the Fed is but the the the
government is now making 97% LTV loans
to a certain class of you know veterans
and things like that so I think it's
actually too high I would almost always
think 97% was too high but definitely it
shouldn't be one fixed number that never
changes but thank you for the question
there there are actually many tools to
control leverage not just mortgage rates
you could you could regulate the margins
on which stock can be purchased you can
regulate the reserve ratios that banks
have to hold in the
in the Federal Reserve you can regulate
capital ratios which we're in the
process of doing and indeed the Basel
three regulations that will go into
effect in some years into the future
actually have a built-in
counter-cyclical provision the capital
requirements of banks are there's a
discretion to raise those in a boom and
lower them in a recession so we're
making some progress on this point in
other areas I think it's between two
hours which is thirty percent thirty
three percent more time than any of the
presidential debates I hope that those
of you who persisted think that there
was at least thirty three percent more
content in this in this discussion and
we you know I think some of the pen also
be happy to stick around and answer the
pickup the questions of those of you
still have them for a few minutes
informally but I think we ought to
liberate the audience and thank you very
much for being good listeners thanks
we can't let you speak last